vous pensez que je vais être acceptée je
suis tellement déçu d'être obligé de
partir ne soyez pas inquiète comme ça le
let
nous avons tous donné un avis favorable
et puis julie le facteur son parti
plaider notre cause trouvé ridicule même
pas du tout la lèque pas du tout c'est
moi je suis certain que le comité de
lille vous autorisera vous installer ici
françois j'espère que vous dites vrai
tout le monde est si gentil avec moi
c'est à mademoiselle hall est donné à la
salle lyonnaise le voilà aujourd'hui
dépêchés pour vous apporter la nouvelle
alors laissez-moi reprendre mon souffle
eh ben c'est d'accord vous pouvez rester
dans l'île aux enfants
c'est merveilleux factor vous merci
monsieur pardon madame salon lecteurs
soyez pas aussi aimé à écouter c'est pas
tous les jours
j'espère que ça ne mettra pas trop julie
continue à me loger chez elle à mais
nous voulons plus mais que voulez-vous
dire facteurs économiques de lille a
décidé la construction d'une petite
maison pour mademoiselle dans left une
petite maison tout juste les enfants
venaient bénédicte loeillet cta deux
années les enfants voilà ce qui se passe
l'eulex va se faire construire une
gentille petite maison mais elle ne
connaît pas le nom des différents
métiers des gens qui participent à la
construction d'une petite maison alors
vous et bien vous allez l'aider et
russie chez moi moi je vais prendre un
petit papier je vais inscrire tous les
métiers dont vous avez besoin multi
beaucoup chacun merci à vous tous de
bien vouloir m'aider
vous savez que d'abord avant de
commencer la construction d'une maison
il faut dessiner des plans qui dessine
des plans
c'est un architecte vous le notez un
fatal en était architecte
une fois que les plans sont destinés eh
bien on commence par monter les murs
c'est le travail c'est pas un plâtrier
c'est très bien c'est pas un massot un
maçon voilà en haut des murs on va poser
le toit ont d'abord posé une charpente
et sous cette charpente ont apposé des
tuiles ou des ardoises le charpentier
c'est celui effectivement du réseau qui
construit la charpente mais une fois que
cette charpente est construite on et
propose des tuiles ou des ardoises qui
fait ce travail c'est presque ça c'est
un couvreur
c'est un couvreur pour les tuiles ou les
ardoises ensuite nous allons poser des
portes et des fenêtres en bois
évidemment c'est le travail d'un
menuisier ça et puis vous savez que ces
fenêtres faudra bien leur poser des
carreaux
alors qui posera les vitres 1 un vitrier
huîtriers très bonne réponse à françois
il faut penser à halo pour l'évier dans
la cuisine et pour la baignoire pas vrai
évidemment le plombier vous continuez à
noter je pense à une chose fera bien
être de la lumière dans la maison alors
pour la lumière un électricien
l'électricien
et puis enfin moi je vois une petite
serrure à l'important c'est un serrurier
ses rues lieu merci les enfants vous
avez été très utile à l'avenir si
beaucoup et bien voilà ne l'êtes moi je
crois qu'avec tous ces corps de métier
c'est d'avoir une bien jolie petite
maison
parce que je les connais moi tout ces
gens là ils travaillent tous comme moi
vite et diana mais on offrait cette
maison d'oublier le principal ce matin
en revenant je savais que je vous ai
apporté ma carte de l'île aux enfants un
as vous savez elle est pas tout à faire
un sentiment que rien n'a changé sur
l'île depuis alors voilà lolette vous
n'avez qu'à choisir
juste derrière le petit bois bon source
est l'endroit le plus agréable de lille
et vous savez que en plus vous aurez
casimir comme voisin je ne vois pas sa
maison la sur le dessin mais je sais
qu'il va se faire construire une
nouvelle maison ici près du petit bois
bonjour tout le monde ça nous l'eau non
non non non non je t'en prie casimir tu
ne vas pas recommencé ce petit jeu avec
la lettre non on commençait quoi bien
c'est une mauvaise habitude quand même
pris avec julie à chaque fois qu'il la
voit il le dit ça le juge que ses
charmes en espagne oui bien sûr et salue
lolo c'est charmant également qu si tu
veux ça me gêne pas du tout merci je
suis très content la nouvelle il nous
reste une nouvelle galette va se faire
construire une petite maison dans l'île
aux enfants
le comité de l'ird a donné la permission
mais non non non il n'est pas question
avec l'avenir c'est une décision du
comité de l'île et ça m'est égal
mais casimir mais ça nous fait plaisir
nous tous mais moi je ne veux pas enfin
casimir tu me déçoit profondément c'est
que j'attendais davantage d'amitié de ta
part enfin je te reconnais plus quasi
mère l'a vraiment dû me dit souvent mais
beaucoup des noms mais enfin c'est vous
vous faites n'importe quoi et vous me
donnez pour responsable à dire que tout
est fait pour que le petit pas que je
reste dans ton
looney tunes m'a rien fait je suis ravi
que tu restes dans notre île
alors pourquoi t'es-tu mis en colère
mais il n'ya que tu ne peux pas faire
une maison à un endroit précis où je
suis déjà en train d'en construire une
on peut voir construire deux maisons une
sur l'eau aux excuses moi ghazi mieux
serait ma maison ailleurs mais il n'en
est pas question non plus haut mais pas
pourquoi mais parce que cette maison que
je suis en train de construire
elle est pour toi merci kazim
[Musique]